this a journey and a ceremony very
familiar to have Majesty the Queen
this has 65th State Opening of
Parliament but this Queen's Speech
certainly is stand out one the audience
waiting for a program for government
this Prime Minister cannot even
implement in such extraordinary time
centuries-old traditions endure black
rod bangs on the door of the Commons to
summon MPs to the lords the Queen waits
as they process through Parliament the
Labour leader in no mood for small talk
the PM picking out a friendly face
amongst the onlookers instead MPs pack
the Lord's as the Queen begins with
brexit my government's priority has
always been to secure the United
Kingdom's departure from the European
Union on the 31st of October and then
quickly onto a government agenda that
reads like mr. Johnson's election
manifesto the NHS new laws will be taken
forward to help implement the national
health services long-term plan in
England law and order my government is
committed to addressing violent crime
and to strengthening public confidence
in the criminal justice system that's in
the Queen to read out your plan in the
House of Lords is one thing but Gerry
Corbin adamant that the PM will never
get it through the Commons there has
never been such a farce as a government
with a majority of -45 setting out a
legislative agenda they know cannot be
delivered in this Parliament the Prime
Minister promised that this Queen's
Speech would dazzle us on closer
inspection mr. speaker it is nothing
more than fool's gold
the Prime Minister with a minority
government Boxton in every which way
still find in room to attack first he
was opposed to No Deal now he seems to
be opposed to
first he was in favor of delivering
brexit now he wants a second referendum
first few first he wanted an electric he
wanted election for a long time now he'd
much rather not his policy on cake is
neither having it nor eating it the
whole debate in Parliament today has
been great theater but it is pure
fantasy Boris Johnson is putting forward
a programme of government but what he
actually wants is to dissolve this
Parliament and have a general election
to try and win a majority to have any
hope of getting this program through
whatsoever this is a manifesto plan
plain and simple and really what matters
isn't what's happening in Parliament but
what's happening over in Brussels right
now in terms of mr. Johnson being able
to get a brexit deal the eu-27
reflecting on mr. Johnson's proposals
ahead of a crunch summit on Thursday the
next few days critical in determining
how this phase of brexit ends better it
beasts Tiny's Westminster